hi everyone welcome to another episode
of q a about history of Science and
Technology
I think for some reason uh Wednesdays
have emerged as my heavy live streaming
day and I've got three live streams
about different things all in uh in
series
um but let's see I see a question here
from Ryan from the submission form you
discuss the history of programming
languages is programming always
associated with computers or were there
other forms of programming interesting
question so it's kind of what's the
history of systematically stated rules
for things
so just to be clear programming in the
form of computers that store their own
programs that was a phenomenon of the
1940s mid to late 1940s
and really started being properly
developed in the 1950s
the idea that is an idea where a
computer a so-called stored program
computer where the program is stored
like the data of the computer in the
electronic memory of the computer
but in many computers the and early
computers
electronic computers there was an idea
that that in many ways the program was
being fed from the outside
very commonly through cards punch cards
or through paper tape and so the idea of
a punch card is you have a bunch of well
let's say it's I don't know
representation of numbers or something
and every column of the punch card has
holes punched out of its square holes in
the case of a punch card punched out of
it in a certain pattern that corresponds
to that particular number and then the
computer reads the punch card by either
some mechanical device or some Optical
device and then that determines what the
computer computes and the idea of
storing the program for what the
computer should be the operations the
computer should be doing as well as the
data like the numbers the computer
should be working on the idea of storing
those things on Punch Cards is actually
quite an old idea
um and the the sort of the big jump for
computers were employing computers
started being able to store their
programs in the memory of the computer
so that in effect among other things you
could operate on the programs just like
you can operate on the data that the
computers were were dealing with so this
idea of punch cards that particular idea
dates to 1800 with a guy called Marisa
card
um and Jacquard invented this uh Loom
that would control
um the uh
where threads go in weaving that one's
doing based on where the holes were
punched out of a punch card and so there
were machines that were making designs
um you know whatever whatever it was
that you were trying to weave you know
some picture of um uh some you know
natural scene with animals in it or
something like this you would represent
that scene in terms of a set of actions
to be taken by the uh by the machine
that was was uh deciding where to put
the threads and you would encode those
actions in terms of how you punch out
the punch card and as the machine is
trying to weave
um the uh uh it um
it would be reading the punch card
moving the the threads around to
eventually produce this this kind of
pattern
so historically the idea of using that
to do things like mathematical
computation that idea was around by the
1830s Charles Babbage
um kind of got that idea in connection
with um uh his uh notion of an
analytical engine so he built this this
Difference Engine
um that was for computing polynomials
using mechanical computation and then he
had a plan to build an analytical engine
that would uh use Punch Cards as a way
to decide what operations it should
um
uh it should um
it should perform and I guess the you
know he had very Charming things like
his his name for the CPU was the mill
because this was a time when Mills like
on uh you know powered by water wheels
and things like that were kind of a big
place where things got made
um
famously then Ada Lovelace had seen the
Difference Engine Back in the 1830s or
so when she was maybe 17 years old or
something 18 years old perhaps and then
a number of years later ended up being
sort of the big Expositor of what
Babbage was trying to do with the
analytical engine Babbage never ended up
being able to build the analytical
engine
um but uh uh Ada Lovelace wrote this
exposition of the article engine kind of
nominally as an introduction to a
translation of lectures that Babbage had
given in Italian not his native language
he was British
um and uh not Ada's native language
either but she translated it and um the
uh actually I guess
maybe translated it and then Ada
Lovelace wrote a kind of introduction
which ended up being longer than the
actual piece itself
um and uh uh was actually the much
clearer exposition of what the sort of
key point of the analytical engine was
and famously she has a a place where she
says um the analytical engine will weave
algebraical patterns much as a Jacquard
Loom weaves patterns of birds and
flowers
so it's kind of the the notion that one
would have these uh
um this way of programming sort of these
mathematical operations these abstract
operations and she also thought about
things like being able to compose music
and so on this way uh these kinds of
much more abstract things
um
Babbage had gotten the idea of like
Computing values of polynomials for
making mathematical tables and then
eventually having a machine print those
out
um but this was a kind of a more
abstracted version of that
um that uh in which uh the so that that
was kind of the the way that
um uh so you know the the implementation
layer of that would have been uh kind of
um
um uh the The Punch Cards the the actual
sort of original design for the
analytical engine
um was going to be sort of a
steam-powered thing although by that
time both Ada Lovelace and Charles
Babbage did know a bunch of people who
were involved in the sort of Faraday
orbit of thinking about electricity so
had the analytical engine actually been
built
um it would uh quite possibly have been
an electrical device not a steam-powered
device not a giant locomotive sized
steam-powered thing I mean the the
actual story of the analytical engine
was uh Babbage
was
um
well Babbage had had in fact inherited
quite a lot of money because his father
was a banker and um he was in fact quite
wealthy and I I some years ago looked at
his account books which are now to be
found in the British Library
um and you could see that he was you
know he he had uh he had substantial
Assets in fact he also uh was involved
in a startup which was a life insurance
company and he was um uh involved in
Computing the uh the Actuarial tables
for that
um which he would have liked to use well
I think he did use his his Difference
Engine to compute some of those tables
um a thing for computing values of
polynomials and so on but um
uh then for a long time Babbage was kind
of um uh once at the British government
to pay for the creation of the
analytical engine and went through many
cycles of of you know this politician
was in power and he was friends with
them and then he would make a
presentation and try and get this to
happen and so on and so on and so on
um Ada Lovelace who was significantly
younger than Charles Babbage
um was very interested in what he was
doing and Ada had uh had already been um
you know she was the daughter of of Lord
Byron the poet and uh then she married
um uh a person his last name was King I
forget his first name now
um who was uh uh account or who became a
count he was actually he'd been a a kind
of a civil servant
um in the British government and for
apparently fairly effective and for and
and he had inherited a uh uh title and I
think he also got sort of elevated a bit
further from his services to the
government but anyway
um Ada became a countess
um and um
uh the
Charles Babbage for his whole life I
think believed that ADA was much
wealthier than he was and was capable of
sort of funding his analytical engine or
at least convincing Queen Victoria to
fund the analytical engine
um upon actual investigation I think if
you look at the account books of Charles
Babbage and Ada Lovelace I think Charles
Babbage was wrong about his estimate of
Ada's net worth versus his net worth
um Ada had the issue that her husband
was very much into real estate and very
much into kind of elaborate construction
projects they had a house in the country
where he was building you know towers
and turrets and things like this and
those finances were not as rosy as they
might have been and Charles Babbage was
much more conservative in these things
and had made I think reasonable
Investments and so on and so his whole
sort of effort to convince Ada to be the
um uh in part sort of the market uh for
the analytical engine project
um well it might have been relevant in
terms of the British government and
certainly Ada was much more politic and
dealing with people and much better at
explaining what was going on Charles
Babbage was much more down at the level
of the specific engineering details I
mean in in a kind of a a modern version
of the Silicon Valley let's start a
company in the garage
um the uh the Charles Babbage version of
that was he had his Workshop set up in
his stable because there were horses not
cars in those days and um uh he had been
he had had a bunch of Engineers who'd
worked on the actual you know making of
the Difference Engine and so on and
making the the whole brass uh sort of
elaborate construction and a lot of
difficult mechanical problems to do with
you know how do you how do you make the
carry bits propagate without having so
much force that you break the the metal
things like this and he'd had a engineer
who worked on that he was not I think a
tremendously good manager of these
projects and he had a tremendous habit
of uh thinking you know he was the the
high-flying mathematical person and he
would delegate the stuff the engineers
then he would be upset that the
engineers weren't doing it very well and
would say he's got a better idea of how
to do the engineering which quite
possible he did have
um and uh it kind of went in a not very
positive Loop
um Ada level Ace actually at one point
there's a nice letter she wrote to
Babbage where she basically says you're
messing up this analytical engine
project let me Ada take over the project
and sort of become its CEO and you
become the CTO and uh then we'll make
this work
and uh it's kind of a fun thing because
I you know I found all these letters and
um in those days there were I think I
had a lot of life and Charles Babbage
lived maybe a mile and a half apart in
London and they were in those days 14
male deliveries per day in that part of
London and so they were able to kind of
exchange messages you know much like
email today so to speak but um through a
combination of the the postal service
and having uh you know people couriers
just take the letters from one place to
another but you see this this lovely
thing where Ada has written this this
giant um uh you know this this letter
proposing that she take over the project
and and Charles Babbage annotates the
letter you know saw AAL his name for for
Ida Lovelace
um uh you know this morning and uh
refused all her requests
his scribbles in the in the margin well
I think by that afternoon he kind of
agreed Yes actually her suggestion was
pretty good she should do this
unfortunately she got sick and uh uh it
never happened had it happened possibly
uh the uh the era of computing would
have occurred at a very different time
and and certainly Babbage had this kind
of idea I think I think either Loveless
was was sort of into this as well of
this sort of cloud computing of the
1840s of um uh having all you know
having the the various difficult
problems of the time whether they're
about navigation or Actuarial tables or
artillery tables and so on have these
things all be fed into the central
analytical engine that would be puffing
away if it was steam-powered um
generating those results that was kind
of the notion at the time now by that
time uh there were Telegraph machines
and so on and so quite possibly it
really would have been a very Victorian
cloud computing story of people you know
the question is tapped in with a
Telegraph and um then the machine runs
and you know the results is tapped back
by by Telegraph so to speak to give give
the answer
but I think the original question here
was sort of the origin of this notion of
specifying rules for things and having
them be executed and was that kind of a
a thing
of computation I think the answer is no
that idea goes back a long way I mean
any time once had sort of plans for
doing something that is a sort of a
specification of rules that then get
followed and you know back in military
drills military operations people had
you know the the Romans no doubt had
their you know let's go into a tortoise
configuration let's do this let's do
that these were things which were
essentially rules that defined executed
by humans in that case rather than by
machines but they were sort of rules
that defined
um how worm would do something like a
program same is true I mean whether it's
uh
um recipes for food or whether it's kind
of um uh things for defining knitting
patterns or whatever else you know there
are many places where people have
defined rules for things similarly in
architecture uh there are certain cases
where people would have oh let's make a
a fought and you know all the forts look
the same and maybe they have some
elaborate fractal pattern of these
so-called star forts that have this sort
of the big the big tower and then the
smaller towers and so on around them
um the uh and people
would work out all the sort of lines of
visibility for these things but those
were cases where there was sort of there
was a plan and then the plan was going
to be executed in some way with people
actually building the thing and one
certainly knows even from Babylonian
times there were cases where there was a
sort of an abstract representation of an
architectural plan which was then built
um so I think those are examples of sort
of rule-based things another another
type of rule-based thing is games where
you know you know the rules for chess or
something and you then get to sort of
follow those rules and that's something
a little bit like programming too I
think
um the uh
the concept I mean when programming was
first out and about it was really very
much
uh in the style of there are certain set
of operations that the computer can do
uh kind of let's have a sequence of
things defined that says do this you
know run the adding adding system you
know the adding machine
and you know the adding system run the
multiplying system take these pieces
from here and there and you know in the
analytical engine those things all
existed one of the things I think Ada
Lovelace
have figured out was the idea of Loops
where you could have sort of this
contingent Loop that would go around it
a different number of times and so on
um but uh you know this idea of do this
than that then that it gets more
elaborated by the time you can have a
loop which says keep doing this until
something happens and so on
um that idea of keep doing this until
something happens uh for instance in in
mathematics
the idea that you would iterate until
you reach a fixed point or something
like this that idea did exist uh in a
variety of places for example Newton's
method for finding a square root which a
variant of which was actually known in
Antiquity
um I've just sort of iteratively going
and getting you know closer and closer
to the square root that's an example of
one of these rule-based things which
kind of iterates until until the answer
is good enough so to speak
subsequently when people kind of tried
to idealize sort of what is what does
mathematics do how does mathematics work
the sort of earliest version of this
involved just a fixed Loop that is uh
saying just go this number of times
where we know how many times it will be
rather than go until something happens
that was the idea of primitive recursion
which arose in the late
as an idealization for a certain parts
of mathematical operations people
thought until the 1920s that that might
be sort of all of the things you need
that that might be the only sort of
iterative type operation that you needed
to sort of specify standard mathematical
functions kind of blown up in 1920 by
this thing called the ackermann function
which is a a function that can be
defined with uh recursively in terms of
the function as defined in terms of
values of the function at smaller
arguments
um but
it doesn't have the feature that you can
always go a fixed number of steps and it
grows too you've improved from the rapid
growth that it has that it doesn't work
that way and so that was an example
where uh one had to do something Beyond
primitive occursion and for example Kurt
girdle and proving girdle's theorem in
1931 had this thing called the general
recursion the so-called mu operator
which was a thing which said keep going
until something happens and that was
sort of a new idea that when computers
sort of first started being out and
about in the in the 1940s and 1950s that
sort of idea of of the um uh do this
until something happens was it was a
pretty early idea I think there are
other Notions of kind of things based on
rules another another area will be logic
uh where you know this was the thing
invented presumably by Aristotle where
it's kind of lifted out of the sort of
arguments that were given in text
and and finding a sort of generalization
of oh this argument is given in terms of
cats it could also be given in terms of
dogs it could also be given abstractly
in terms of peace
uh if you have this particular pattern
of ANS and O's and Knots and so on then
it follows this other pattern of ants
and O's and Knots one could think of
that as another example of kind of a
rule-based system and by the way by the
uh 1830s when George boole had sort of
cleaned up the and mathematicized the
notion of logic had come up with with uh
Boolean algebra and the sort of
formalization of logic formal logic
um that people like Lewis Carroll
Charles Dodson were into and so on
um that was a uh by that point people
started actually making machines for uh
mechanical devices that would kind of
resolve uh simple logic
um uh you know would would give you the
answers you know you say make a machine
that computes P and Q and not r or
something and you would set things to
represent p and Q and r and then you'd
look at another part of the machine and
it would have the um uh it would have
the results from that
um and that was that was kind of another
an early form of mechanical computer
um
so
that's some uh yeah so those are a few
examples
let's see
uh
this comment didn't IBM have its own
extremely labor-intensive Telegraph
system I well telegraphs were invented
long before IBM as a company came into
existence I mean telegraphs
uh were invented what Samuel Morse was
like 1833 something like that
um by the time I mean IBM's
uh was originally something like the
something rather the hollow Earth
tabulating company something like that
uh this person Hermann holloweth who was
involved in Punch Cards and I think
their first big contract was the census
the U.S census around 19 maybe the 1910
census I'm not sure and where the big
idea was to have census forms be encoded
by Punch Cards and then if you wanted to
tabulate to count the number of people
who have this characteristical that
characteristic you could do that almost
mechanically by looking at sort of the
the holes in the Punch Cards so to speak
um
let's see
well there are lots of questions here
about different kinds of things uh Ollie
asks how do you think Ada would view the
current age of AI
that's an interesting question
you know
that is an interesting question uh
you know llms large language models of
which Chachi PT is is an example
sort of their big story is how do you
continue a piece of text you know you've
given a prompt what's the way to
continue that
I suspect
that ADA would have
seen that I mean she was uh the um
she kind of you know her father had been
Lord Byron the poet she never really
knew him
um and uh the um
um but she much to her mother's dismay
because her mother uh had the sort of
ugly divorce from from Lord Byron and
and the the kind of the the
repercussions of that lasted a century
with the with the you know uh attacks on
both sides from the people trying to
claim that um uh Anna milibank I guess
was her name
um uh and another bank then
um was was a terrible person and that
Byron was a terrible person and so on
and there were all these attacks on Ada
that resulted from that and it just a a
horrible mess that goes back and forth
in the kind of gossip columns the
Victorian gossip columns and books and
so on I mean that you know there were
all these claims about uh how you know
Ada was a um uh was an out of control
Gambler and she'd gamble the way the
Family Jewels three times and things
this is not true so far as I could tell
it's in fact completely false
um the uh but this was part of the kind
of the gossip from um uh that came from
the the pro Lord Byron auntie and Miller
Bank
um uh faction
in any case the um uh
um the thing that um
I've forgotten
um the uh
uh you know I think Ada
would have perhaps thought about this
idea of of completions as being a little
bit like what it takes to fill in a
piece of poetry because it's like okay
What word could go next well there's a
limited set of possibilities given that
you want the poem to scan in a
particular way rhyme in a particular way
and so on so I think that piece of sort
of the the construction of a large
language model might have been somewhat
familiar to her
in terms of the ability
for a um
uh you know I I think this notion
well to me there are sort of two sides
of what's going on one is the kind of uh
the statistical learn from what is out
there on the web and do kind of
completions and things like this that's
you know the llm story the other side of
the story is kind of the wolf and
language side of uh you know compute
what can be computed based on having a
very structured view of the world
um certainly that second part had a long
tradition going back to people like
leibniz who thought about doing that
um I think uh Charles Babbage
would have been quite into that kind of
idea he was very much of a sort of
organized knowledge although he was uh
you know kind of stuck to things like
make mathematical tables astronomical
tables things of this kind
um so I think that um and the idea of
let's just compute mechanically
um you know I think one of his famous
quotes
um uh when he was trying to build some
logarithm tables
um back in probably the 1820s or
something
um uh I think the the quote is you know
I Wish by God this could be done by
steam which is you know translated in a
modern terminology that would be you
know done automatically so to speak
um and so I think that that would be you
know the idea that one could sort of
compute things automatically would be
sort of more his thing but I think Ada
would would kind of probably associate
the kind of you know how do you continue
based on how things were continued
before as something not that dissimilar
to her sort of family business of poetry
she she at one point um uh sort of
thought of herself as a as a sort of a a
um a poetess of um uh of uh of of
Science of of kind of the exposition of
science I mean I think her big in a
sense both her big skill and her big
point was to kind of see the big picture
of what was going on which turned out in
the case of computation there was a very
big picture to see which she managed to
get a reasonable glimpse of
um even as you know folks like Babbage
were seeing much more the micro details
of you know we're going to get this
thing and it's going to turn this crank
so that this number will come out in
this way and so on
so
um
uh
uh yeah I think the um
I mean this whole notion of kind of
entrepreneurism and so on which people
think of as being terribly modern is
really I mean the fact that Charles
Babbage was involved in this this
insurance startup is uh uh is an example
of that that's not such a modern thing
and I think the although it is the case
that the kind of the complexity of like
starting a company and the sort of the
the bureaucracy around it has definitely
gone way down at least in most countries
um over the last century or so and and
that's uh that's kind of a different
story
um
let's see
Satoshi comments I wonder what would
have happened if Newton or Gauss had had
access to digital computers yeah I think
you know Gauss was a pretty decent hand
calculator
um you know one confined his places
where he was trying to figure out
properties of primes where he just
enumerated a whole bunch of primes and
um the uh you know was trying to
empirically work things out of course
many mathematicians don't realize that
people like Gauss did those kinds of
experiments because all the Gauss sort
of published was I proved this theorem
here's this result rather than you know
I tried it on ten thousand numbers and
this is the results I got
um I don't know about Newton's I've
never looked how have I
looked at Newton's I don't know whether
the um
uh you know handwritten calculation and
so on
um I know leibniz I have looked at his
handwriting calculation he was pretty
bad at it he made a lot of mistakes
um he was better at algebra which was
much more something that was sort of a
more newfangled thing and probably more
exciting than these big tables of
numbers and so on
um I think uh
you know the answer for example for
Gauss surely is that just a huge number
of things that Gauss might have wondered
whether they were true about prime
numbers or other kinds of mathematical
things
um would be uh
um
uh what would have been worked out
differently you know I'm reminded when
Mathematica first came out in 1988
um a rather lovely review of
mathematical written by a mathematician
um had a title like you know if Gauss
had a mouse
um and uh was was talking about this
question
um I think that might have been written
by a
uh was mathematologic person now now no
longer alive but um uh I'm also reminded
by just uh just I I have to tell this
story because I thought it was amusing
the um uh uh when we first announced
Mathematica June 23 1988 uh was a
different time the web didn't exist the
uh the way you communicated things was
with press conferences and so we had
such a thing in Silicon Valley actually
in Santa Clara and invited uh lots of
newspapers and such like and uh you know
most of which had written most of their
story because we briefed them beforehand
and you know they beautifully showed up
and then filed their story and and off
it went to the newspaper but um we had
invited a number of things like
mathematicians to the press conference
and one of them wrote some rather lovely
account uh of of that event
um a number of interesting people showed
up to the press conference
um uh among them actually quite a few
kind of uh I would say even warring
Chieftains of Silicon Valley
um Steve Jobs was there and um uh uh who
hadn't been out in public match because
he was in the middle of working on his
next company uh called Next that hadn't
yet released its computer and
um there were
uh gosh lots of people were lots of
interesting people Gordon Bell the
developer of the vax for digital was
there those people from IBM
um some Microsystems antibacterial shine
Bill Joy I think yeah and uh a variety
of variety of other people all sorts of
interesting crowd
um uh uh chat from Sun actually had the
um uh the bright idea of making sure
that everybody who was there kind of
signed a copy of the of the Mathematica
book which had just came out so that's
kind of a nice uh collection of of
interesting signatures of the time in
any case the the person who was there uh
as I think representing some math
publication actually but really a
mathematician uh wrote that you know
he'd sort of expected he was coming to
this thing that was going to be a a math
talk so to speak and it rapidly became
clear that this was not a kind of math
talk that this person had ever seen
before I think this was probably the
first and perhaps only press conference
that they ever went to
um but it was it was rather a Charming
Clash of Worlds
um that uh that worked out quite nicely
but any case the um
uh
the question here
uh from Brian uh any thoughts about um
so that was a um
um
that was a a thing created by a person
called conard zuza the USC
um
and I don't know that much about it I I
know a certain amount about Conrad zuza
um Conor zuza was an early computer
Pioneer in Germany
who um uh after the second world war
built up a company Azusa computer
company that made a series of computers
and um had some degree of Commercial
Success uh but I think was eventually
overtaken by a sort of a different
generation of electronic computers but I
suppose one of Con Ed zuza's claims to
fame was something he did during Second
World War I mean I should say in kind of
the connectivity of History
was also interested in kind of versions
of cellular automata though primarily
more like finite difference models where
you have a grid of values and there's a
discrete grid but every value on the
grid is uh is is a real number whereas
in cellular automata the values on the
grid are discrete numbers
but um towards the end of Zeus's life
this was in the 1980s
um yeah I actually exchanged some
letters with him and I think his very
last papers were actually much more in
line with things I've done on cellular
automata
um because he read a bunch of things I
wrote
um and so there's sort of a confusing
thing because you know as you know
happily his life span many decades and
um the uh in the final decade so to
speak it sort of overlap the things that
I'd done in sort of a related area that
that's led to a certain degree of
confusion about
um uh uh sort of what was he doing
earlier on well it wasn't actually quite
the same thing as cellular automatically
had this idea of what he called
calculating space the German name for it
which I can't say but um
the um and that was something I think
he'd maybe written in the 60s 1960s or
so but that was kind of an idea of
discrete space
he wasn't really very much into physics
I mean he he talks about physics but I
don't think he ever had learned that
much about physics
but any case the the thing that was an
earlier
uh sort of Adventure of his was during
the second World War uh he
um
made a a binary mechanical computer uh
presumably
and it's a little bit unclear what
happened because the
the computer there's one photograph of
it uh he made it in his uh sort of
parents house in Berlin
and um it was uh well the the sort of
the standard story is that house was
bombed the computer was destroyed and
the only thing that remains is this
Photograph and then many many years
later I think 1980s probably uh Conrad
zuza and his son horse Souza were
responsible for sort of making a
reconstruction of that computer for the
um uh Blanchard Museum in Berlin and um
uh that reconstruction doesn't look that
much like what's in the photographs but
supposedly it worked the same way as
what's in the photograph and I I a
number of years ago I I actually
um met up with horse Souza and looked at
that um that machine and it's not very
easy to tell that much from it
but the real question that I got very
curious about is so what did happen to
the Z1 the very first computer built
around 1944 and you know what were its
Origins and what physically happened to
it because it's a big metal object and
uh you know you can we we did find out
um in uh
I think we even got a photograph of the
um uh from aerial reconnaissance of the
uh bomb site where a bomb had been
dropped on that you know on that house
but the question then was uh so what
really happens to a computer when it's
you know in a house that's bombed is it
vaporized is it you know what happens to
it it's a big lump of metal
um it was already mysterious to me where
did a big lump of metal come from in
1944 because metal was you know of great
strategic value and uh uh you know
wasn't self-evident how you would get
uh how you've got a big chunk of metal
what I learned actually much more
recently Conor zuza was was not
officially in the military and quite why
I'm not sure
um I mean he was a college student at
that time
um but apparently he had um a friend in
um well I think in the SS actually and
also had some connection I learned
recently from somebody I had some
connection with the German air force and
so presumably that had something to do
with how he managed to get a giant lump
of metal to make a computer out of but
in any case the the question I mean for
me the sort of an interesting story
fragment this must have been
oh how long ago a decade ago or
something now
um I was visiting this Museum in Germany
and looking at this computer talking to
the son of of Conor zuza and um the
woman who was the curator of that part
of the museum and it's like uh you know
oh what happened to the original
computer while it was in this house it
was bombed and eventually it's like
where is that house
oh well actually it's five blocks from
here unfortunately I had to kind of
um leave at that point and couldn't go
and do that investigation but we have
subsequently done a bit more
investigation and had many more
conversations about what really happened
to the computer and the computer has
still not been tracked down because it
was a an early story was while the
computer was in the basement of the
house it had been moved to the basement
because there were Air Raids and so on
and um okay so then I asked people who
know about you know Urban archeology and
so on you know what happens if you know
you have a house it collapses there's a
computer it's made of metal it's in the
basement and you know what happens and
it's like most people said well it'll
still be there you know it might be
smooshed a bit but it'll still be there
you don't it doesn't uh you know it's
it's not um you know that's that's no
worse of a situation than many things
that have happened to things that are
still preserved from antiquity
so then
further investigation further
discussions it turned out there was a um
an air raid shelter nearby and there was
a well maybe it was moved to the Airaid
shelter well maybe not uh where was that
well there were two houses they were
next to each other they've been rebuilt
and um uh it's kind of like um uh you
know so I I for a while was thinking
about sort of uh mounting some kind of
urban archeology Expedition because I
think it'd be really cool to actually
unearth you know a computer from 1944
that um uh was perhaps the first sort of
binary mechanical computer
um and but I never got around to doing
it and it became clear that uh there
were
um it wasn't it wasn't clear you might
think everybody would be like very
gung-ho to find this computer but it was
it was clear that that wasn't really the
case and it's sort of a question of why
and
um uh I don't know the answer I mean uh
you know it's one of these things that
one can speculate on but I think the um
uh you know generally uh you know what
one speculation would be the computer
didn't really exist I think that's not
correct because there is a photograph
the photograph seems fairly convincing
um it's uh I think the computer existed
did the computer work
who knows maybe it didn't work
um maybe it was um uh did the computer
have components that were had come from
some unsavory Source possibly yes
um you know these are these are some of
the the the the things one might think
about but anyway so the the answer is I
I don't know about
um uh you know what happened to that
computer it's a mystery somebody can go
out and solve it uh go find the um uh
that that computer
um playing Kung cool how cool I think
was a a programming scheme for that
computer and I I really don't know much
about it I'm telling you only the
ambient story so to speak
RBS comments here isn't mathematics
itself following rules yes I suppose one
could say that it was although
in a sense
the euclidean the tradition that started
with Euclid of let us prove this you
know if you read what Euclid says
uh it's mostly things like you know
construct a pentagon
it's like you're defining the goal but
you're not saying how you get there one
of the great things about computational
computers is it's all about the steps
that let you get to something and
defining those steps and then you know I
think I've spent some part of my life
doing is okay computer here are the
rules now go run with them and see what
happens so to speak which is very
different from
um sort of the Euclid
to construct you know a typical form in
his in Greek is is something like to
construct a pentagon a regular pentagon
and then it's like okay now you've got
the goal now go figure out how to do
that with these with these sort of set
of of uh of other goals that you have
achieved in the past
and so in a sense that's the notion of
the you know a view of mathematics is
it's all about proofs and you've got you
know the theorems are out there and
you're defining what those theorems are
and then the process of mathematics is
to go find that proof to go build the
scaffolding that gets to the place where
you're trying to get to that is really
different from the computation idea
which is you've defined the program now
you run it and you see what happens
and and for example when Whitehead and
Russell in 1910 wrote their big
principia Mathematica effort to sort of
formalize mathematics to have a to
derive mathematics from logic I think
one of the things that they got wrong
was they thought the process of
mathematics was the process of proof and
I think that uh in in what became clear
and in the sense of our own efforts with
Mathematica and what's now open language
and so on uh make clear is that the it
is much more valuable to be able to do
the forward computation to figure out
what's true than to say I've got this
thing it's ethereum I'm pretty sure it's
true now go find me the steps that fills
that in from the actions that I started
from so I think mathematics in a sense
is a rule following thing now there are
examples that are more rule-based so for
example uh the Fibonacci sequence you
know F of n is equal to F of n minus one
plus F of n minus two uh that was
defined with some clarity by Berlin of
Leonardo Fibonacci
in 12
first decade of the of the 1200s um 1205
maybe
um in his book Libra abachi the book of
the Abacus which was actually a book
kind of a manual for merchants in in
Italy in in Venice and Pisa and so on
um for uh you know how to use an abacus
and and really it's big it's big
innovation was bringing Hindu Arabic
base 10 numerals to the west where where
it had been that um uh that Roman
numerals had been used previously and so
in a sense the fibon archery sequence
which he put at the very end of his
Libra about she is kind of an exercise
imagine rabbits in this enclosure and
they have this you know successive baby
rabbits and successive years and so on
and that was sort of defining a rule a
recursive rule that's kind of a little
bit more like the sort of forward
definition that we're used to from
programs
uh
let's see
um
uh
oh boy lots of interesting questions
here all right
um question from spare here can you talk
about the history of cybernetics and the
idea of feedback loops
uh you know cybernetics as a name came
from Norbert wiener in the 1930s or 40s
um
you know his big thing I think I've
talked about this here before was sort
of
control of machines and animals and so
on and how do you do how do you manage
to you know put your finger in a
particular place it involves sort of a
you look at your finger where is it
going well it's going too far that way
oh no pull it back the other way and um
uh you know and it's kind of this
feedback process of looking at what
happened and then uh sort of feeding it
back now
this notion of of kind of how do you get
a system that kind of it tries to home
in on a particular thing like it tries
to home in on you know do you get the
device to precisely follow this place do
you get the autopilot to precisely you
know to go at this particular altitude
and so on how do you get that kind of
feedback mechanism to work I think the
earliest examples of these kinds of
things were various kinds of Governors
that were used for example James Watt I
believe had a had a form of Governor
that was used on steam engines and I
think the way that one worked was it has
it's this thing that spins around and
has these weights on it and depending on
how fast it's spinning the weights will
will be pulled out by centrifugal force
and that will cause it to I think maybe
close a valve or something that makes it
run slower and that mechanism of kind of
the you know when the thing is going too
fast the the thing closes itself down
that mechanism was certainly knowing
that the the what governor was a thing
um back in the 17
I think 1776 that was a famous date for
um a memorable date from the American uh
uh founding and and also from the
founding of the sort of what steam
engine and so on
um but I think that was one of the
innovations that what had was this idea
of Governors now I know uh James Maxwell
picked that up and has a paper he wrote
he didn't write that many papers and
they were pretty hard-hitting but he
wrote one called on Governors and I'm
pretty sure that contained some sort of
early control theory kinds of kinds of
methods that must have been written
in the
1840s I would guess 1850s Maybe
I'm not sure
um
in any case the so those kinds of things
were around the sort of mechanical
Governor devices were around
then uh wiener
famously worked on an anti-aircraft gun
that used those kinds of things in World
War II and um I think really kind of got
more into the the electronic version of
that kind of feedback I'm trying to
think about other examples of that type
of thing because I think that the
uh let me think about this the um
amplifiers electronic amplifiers that
came into existence
in
uh let me see and the
originally
well let's see the vacuum tube was
invented well there were
yeah the 1920s and 1930s I think was
when the first kind of um
now there's something I'm confusing in
my history here because uh for radio you
need amplifiers and there were oh yeah
that's right there were Crystal
amplifiers first of all but I'm I'm now
a little bit confused about how that
works because Hertz
in the 1880s had 1890s maybe had
demonstrated kind of radio transmission
I mean Hertz Heinrich Hertz had this
idea okay we've got Maxwell's equations
from there from the field that implies
that there must exist these
electromagnetic waves that was known and
then Hertz said well let me do a physics
experiment and see if I can pick up an
electromagnetic wave generated by a
spark here pick it up somewhere else and
yes he managed to do that people asked
him famously you know is there any use
for this kind of physics
um experiment oh no he said no I don't
there's no use at all well of course
that turned into radio in the hands of
people like Marconi
um who developed it's it's kind of uh
large-scale commercial applications but
in any case the um uh
amplifiers oh my
that was
invented I just wrote a little bit about
this chat recently actually
um the inventor of the triode
oh my gosh the person who founded uh RCA
radio Corporation of America and
um oh I'm blanking on the name but in
any case the um uh uh that person
strangely showed up in my um recent uh
writings because he was a student of uh
uh Josiah Willard Gibbs uh big wheel in
in um
in thermodynamics uh at the uh in the in
the late 1800s and so on
um and uh professor at Yale
um and that was one of his few graduate
students was was that person
um in any case that was um I I think
by the time you have electronic
amplifiers and so on there is sort of a
feedback loop in those electronic
circuits that's another example the
whole idea of sort of the importance of
feedback I mean we know is very big on
on promoting that then in terms of sort
of feedback as a mechanism for
everything in the world uh the whole
System Dynamics
uh development particularly around Jay
Forrester uh among other things the
inventor of uh magnetic core memory uh
long time MIT person I met him a few
times
um the uh uh he was very big on the the
whole idea of System Dynamics and this
whole idea of sort of feedback as a key
feature of sort of General systems in
the world in fact I think uh out nowhere
I live in in uh in Concord Massachusetts
there was a sort of an effort for quite
a while to teach System Dynamics in uh
in K-12 schools
um as sort of key ideas for
understanding how the world Works in
terms of these kinds of you know a
series of feedback loops and so on
um I I don't know how I mean I think
that whole Enterprise of sort of finding
these Global kind of uh sort of Loops
for how the world Works which which
revolved around some of these economic
models in the 1960s
um didn't didn't really pan out as as
well as people had hoped and it didn't
hasn't really developed as strongly as
might have been expected
uh there's a question here about uh from
Quinn how are the history of education
and programming connected when do
degrees in programming become
significant
um oh that's an interesting question
with a lot of modern tentacles I have to
say
um
look in in education
the
sort of the codification of what's worth
learning
had
there were versions of this and
Antiquity I mean the scribal schools for
example in in Babylon where people were
being taught to be scribes and to learn
to write I think once you've learned
basic writing there were like five
different kinds of things you also
learned whether it was astronomy or
astrology or whether it was something
else there were things you would write
about on the little tablets you were
using and then by the time of uh you
know Plato's Academy and things like
this uh there was some codification of
sort of what was worth learning I think
the what is it the Trivium or something
and um the various different
combinations of rhetoric and Mathematics
and uh and so on and and logic managed
to make its way in there and I think the
um
um sort of through the Middle Ages there
was a pretty well-defined set of of
things one learned at least in the
western tradition
um and some of those revolved around uh
sort of read the Bible read Aristotle
um you know Aristotle was sort of the an
early encyclopedist in effect having
written about you know things from kind
of the sea creatures to a Theory of
physics to kind of the idea of logic and
so on he really he really covered you
know his Works were sort of encyclopedic
works and some of what he much of what
he wrote was sort of somewhat factual
and uh and not a bad summary but he also
kind of segued into the much more
theoretical and hypothetical and some of
that is is you know to Modern Eyes just
utterly wrong I mean the the views of
kind of very much anthropomorphizing
nature in many ways of of uh you know
nature abhorse a vacuum and so and so on
um the uh these kinds of ideas of of
what nature wants which seem out of
place in in much of modern thinking and
also Aristotle didn't have the idea of
connecting mathematics to Nature in fact
he didn't even have the idea of
connecting logic to Nature had he had
that idea that would have been something
much closer to things I've tried to do
in sort of thinking about computation as
models of nature but he didn't do that
for him logic was a kind of a
codification of of rhetoric of the ways
that arguments got made but any case the
the sort of tradition of teaching
uh continued in that way there were it's
worth remembering that universities in
the west you know which originate in the
1200s in bologna and and Paris and and
Oxford and so on
um those universities were mostly for
training for the church
and that was really their main you know
it's you learned the things that were
relevant for that
there were also quite separate from the
the sort of the um the the scholars at
universities and so on with their who
often ended up going from town to town
because they were sometimes became uh
you know not well liked in the local
area which is why you know an awful lot
of ramparts and things on early
universities that make one feel like you
know the academy is under attack
um but in any case I don't really quite
know uh what well in a case a separate
story of of the sort of the politics of
of um of Academia from the 1200s on so
to speak but one of the things that was
quite separately from the academic world
and the and the kind of church training
type world was the merchant world and
the world of guilds and the worlds of
Crafts People And Trades people and so
on and I think somewhat into you know
separate from that again was the banking
world but this idea of merchants and
Merchants who died with money and so on
that was an area and there were people
who made a living essentially teaching
Merchants for example how to do
mathematics like there was that was what
um Fibonacci had been doing later on in
English I think the first book that uh
was um uh sort of the the secret art of
of Reckoning of calculating a person
called Richard record
um was the author of that and it's
interesting to see these things because
you know there have been all these fads
in math teaching about you know what's
the right way to teach long
multiplication or whatever what's the
right way to teach these different kinds
of things back in the day those fads
were alive and well in the 1600s and so
on you know Richard record was was out
talking about the rule of Z's I think
which was as you know you had this whole
scheme where you can see in his book has
this whole thing where you're
calculating by by sort of putting
numbers in some particular pattern and
then doing this thing and and magically
the result pops out and you can you the
merchant have an advantage over the
other Merchants because you can
calculate faster I mean it's kind of
it's quite Finance from the 1600s so to
speak
um but at that time it was like I don't
know calculating interest rates and
things of this kind
but um
this but that the training of merchants
so to speak and learning about how to do
calculation quite separate from the
universities there were things the
astrologers
who sort of segued into the astronomers
again yet separate again and insofar as
their work was used for navigation yet
separate again
um so this idea now it's worth
remembering that sort of the the whole
kind of uh the the streamlining of of
sort of learning at universities things
like law came in medicine came in that
was in some places that were slowed down
by for example bans on human dissection
in in in England as opposed to Scotland
that kind of uh slowed down the sort of
ingestion of medicine into Universities
at least in that place for that time but
then uh you know gradually uh these
things kind of came in now by the time
you know uh Galileo for example was a
university Professor
um and he was a uh a sort of a mixed I
think he'd done medical stuff and he did
mathematics his father had been a music
Professor
um so you know by the 1600s there was a
certain sort of
um uh you know tradition there of of of
things being done and taught at
universities
um you know Newton was also a professor
at Cambridge University uh of
mathematics
but um
uh okay but so there are these
traditions of teaching at universities
by the time there started to be sort of
organized uh K-12 schools I think the
first of those uh that one knows about
were um well there's certainly one in
England that dates to the 1600s
uh what is it Christ's Hospital school
or something like that uh famously they
Newton was one of the Consultants who
worked on curriculum for for that school
and and suggested calculus I believe is
one of the things to teach there
um but uh you know there have been these
Traditions like the the high school I
went to Eaton was started in 1450 I
think
um but it was for the you know for the
education of poor Scholars so to speak
and paid for by the king when I was
there the the uh the scholars were still
getting uh supposedly a piece of the um
endowment that had been put down in 1450
and um there was this uh there had been
a um a tradition that on a particular
day they would give the scholars you
know their little piece of the Endowment
for that year and I think back in the
early 1900s
um the there had been a choice of you
could either get thruppence three three
pennies or a pig and um uh no actually
much much earlier than that sorry much
earlier than that that had been the the
you know thruppence or a pig was the um
was the sort of choice for the for the
kids and um I I know the story that was
circulating at least when I was at Eden
was that um back in the must have been
what 1920s perhaps
two of the uh students who were there as
as scholar kids were um uh
um
yeah I think Harold MacMillan who later
became prime minister in England and
John Maynard Keynes who was a became a
well-known Economist and the the story
which who knows whether the story told
by kids passed down by by generations of
kids is accurate but the the story was
that um everybody was confused at the
time about how could it be the case that
there was a choice between threepence
and a pig but yet by that time a pig
cost a lot more than thruppence and of
course Keynes was was Keen to to note
apparently according to the story that
um yes well there's this thing inflation
that happens in economies and uh perhaps
at that point as a you know 13 year old
or something he might have given his
explanation of why inflation happens
which may or may not have developed as
as time went on but any case by the time
I mean just to give a sense of you know
eaten for example taught Classics Latin
Greek
um taught things like that uh
mathematics education had eaten had been
pretty much non-existent it consisted of
reading Euclid and Greek and that
persisted right up until the 1950s
um and that was kind of so you know
mathematics education wasn't really much
of a thing there I think um uh but you
know that that was Eden was an unusual
you know one of the unusual so-called
Public Schools where kids would go to be
educated not at home but in public so to
speak at an outside school now of course
that all changed for example in England
in 1870 there was the An Education Act
which sort of brought in the idea of
what we would Now call public education
that is sort of the government provides
schools for for everybody to go to and
at that time there's sort of a question
about what Fields would be included in
in public education and you know the the
three R's you know Reading Writing
arithmetic were kind of the the big
things that uh yeah writing doesn't
start with an R I know
um the uh uh
in um uh with sort of the big things
that were that were being taught and in
a sense that sort of curriculum setup
has persisted in the K-12 World until
today
and um the uh uh you know I think one of
the things that I find really
interesting is that computation is the
first really important new idea
that has come into existence come into
the world since the time when public
education was developed and sort of how
that merges is really an interesting
question
but then
so okay the question was asked about
programming education
what a mess that is
so at
well okay so when computers were first
being built in the 1950s for example you
know IBM which was building a bunch of
these computers would provide
programming courses and people would do
them people would study mathematics
chemistry uh people would then do these
programming courses and that's how they
learned to program and the early books
of you know Fortran programming and
things they were they came out of those
courses the idea that there would be
sort of an academic subject of learning
to program it was seen much more I think
as a trade
um an intellectual trade but a trade
nevertheless rather than a sort of a
academic kind of thing and very few
universities had you know some
universities got computers and by the
time they had computers they had sort of
a computer center and sometimes there
would be things that sort of revolved
around that computer center
and I think I mean one could talk about
individual universities and how they
kind of got online with having some sort
of computer activities
but
the idea of a kind of computer science
as a field really what had happened uh
you know it sometimes it it occasionally
grew a little bit out of mathematics but
mathematicians usually pushed it aside
um that's certainly what happened that
for example The Institute for advanced
study where I worked back in the early
80s they um John Von Neumann had built a
computer there in the 1950s when he died
in 1957 I guess the the mathematicians
at The Institute he was officially there
as a mathematician we're like let's get
rid of this computer it's a big messy
thing and Tom Watson then CEO of IBM
sort of kindly offered to to uh you know
get it taken away so to speak and and um
uh Von Neiman had been a consultant for
IBM for on computer design for for a
while in any case the uh and by the way
I can say that um you know I was at an
event with some mathematicians and some
people who'd gone to IBM from Von
Neiman's computer project effect it was
sort of a a reunion for some of these
people back uh must have been
1984-85 something like that and I kind
of initiated the the questioning of of
uh you know what really had the
mathematicians thought was going to
happen with computers
um back when Von Neumann was around and
there was a let's say a vigorous
discussion uh about what their
expectations had been and that they
hadn't really been as as as hopeless as
um uh as as people had made out
but any case there was you know
computers they sort of arose sometimes
out of a little bit out of math but not
so much more often out of electrical
engineering where people were thinking
about the actual building of the
computer oh you're going to run a
computer it needs electrical engineers
to keep it running sometimes out of
business schools where it was kind of
more a um a story of uh kind of well
computers are going to be used in the
workplace they used for doing uh kind of
financial calculations and so on so
that's a thing relevant to to business
students things like that but it's sort
of a messy history and the thing that
became computer science in universities
uh really had originated I think in
probably the 1960s or so a lot of
theoretical computer science different
places in different ways like you know
MIT had uh really I think that kind of
got launched with um uh the lab for
computer science which was from the
early 1960s and then the AI lab these
were both big government contracts that
sort of caused an effort in these areas
to get planted in that case at MIT you
know Harvard just down the street didn't
have a computer science department for
the longest time I mean I remember when
that University was trying to hire me
back in the early early 1980s
um they really didn't have you know they
had a an applied sciences area that
um uh was um
uh uh you know in which there was sort
of a few people that at least one of
whom is still there
um and maybe two even
um who were sort of computer science
professors
um but I'm not even completely yeah I
think they used that term I think they
were not mathematics professors but they
were very theoretical and um actually
there have been other people there who
did theoretical work in computer science
but any case that was very much of a
computer science as a theoretical area
um you know they've been worked on on
planet automata there
um and again now I'm I'm it's the
history is always confusing there was
another person
um Howard Aiken who had been there in
the 1940s working on um uh kind of a a
mechanical electromechanical computer
um that I don't think connected that was
part of the engineering effort and I
don't think connected to the work that
was done on what became called computer
science that was quite theoretical but
this was typical of many universities
that there were sort of theoretical
computer science there were a set of
courses
people did this was true in the 1970s
and so on
um where people would study Finance
automata they would study compiler
design they would study logic uh Boolean
algebra things like this
um this sort of was computer science and
um uh I suppose the um uh most of the
work that had been done on you know
algorithm development you know the the
Sorting algorithms quick sort and things
invented at companies
um now you know you can kind of see a
bit of a snapshot of the history of
computer science in Don knutz art of
computer programming series of books
which he kind of who's whose design was
set down who's kind of architecture of
those books I think was from 1964 and it
was planned as a series of eight books
and um
uh the
um what is it I think uh there's one
about sorting and searching there's one
about numerical algorithms and so on
and and uh this kind of was the idea of
computer science now Don has now reached
volume 4 out of his eight volumes
um some of the subsequent volumes were
about languages uh in the sense of
parsing compiling uh you know final
photometer things like this
um it's uh it is a little bit um uh I I
mean I consider done
been with a friend and um uh I certainly
um both inspired by and horrified by his
effort of building this sort of the the
the definitive scholarly work on
computer science started so long ago and
he's now at volume four and I think even
volume four keeps on expanding into more
and more subparts of volume four and I
wonder whether I I need to ask him
whether he actually has even drafts of
volumes five six seven eight I think he
did say to me recently that um you know
the field had evolved a bit and maybe he
would change his plan a bit for the
other volumes
um I can say that when I was um when I
was at Caltech actually this is late
1970s
um and I decided when I was going to
build my first big computer system SMP
that was in 1979
um I decided I better learn some
computer science so I went to the
Caltech bookstore and I thought I'm
going to buy all the books on the Shelf
on computer science and it was a you
know the small you know a foot and a
half of books maybe and I sort of read
through them over a weekend so to speak
and they were that was sort of a that
was computer science and it was all
theoretical stuff about compilers and
and so on at that time
so you know the Early Education of
computer science and universities really
was of that kind and even when I started
our company in 1986
um it was hard to hire people who'd come
through computer science because they
knew a bunch of this theoretical stuff
they didn't really need that theoretical
stuff although I thought it was
interesting you know I'd worked on
things related to that myself but it
wasn't what we needed for software
development and then this huge pivot
happened in the 1990s I guess when there
was a big pressure of students who
wanted to study computer science because
they knew that there were jobs to be had
in programming this huge pivot as
universities you know started hiring
computer science faculty in droves
um I mean I could tell you about many
different universities that really
didn't have any effort in computer
science back in the 1980s and you know
then that sort of all developed uh in
the 1990s and Beyond I think think that
um
and then the question was well how do
you teach
you know what is computer science well a
lot of computer science as people want
to be learning it is about programming
and about how do you program well it
turns out a lot of good programmers
didn't go to Computer Science school
um and you know so it's a very strange
thing that it's kind of like you know
lots of good actors didn't go to acting
school either it's it's one of these
things where it's not obvious that sort
of knowing that the the
um uh kind of the the sort of the the
the the the kind of the the template for
how to program and learning that in a
kind of mechanical learning kind of way
is not necessarily the best thing but
anyway that's been a it's been a big
thing and that's been sort of a huge uh
sort of effort of universities is to
train all these programmers because
after all people say programming is this
job that is going to be you know a nice
stable well-paying job and so on because
the world always needs more programmers
well of course that was a great idea
until 2023
um and in you know for myself you know
I've spent the last 40 years or more
trying to as much as possible automate
the process of programming that's why
our company has been able to build as
much technology as it has with us
comparatively few people as we have
um because it's uh We've automated many
many layers of what amounts to
programming and that's what sort of
that's one of the ideas of our
computational language is you know make
it so that it is from sort of human
thinking that's where the language is
kind of connected it's kind of this
General way of formalizing things which
by the way happens to be implemented by
computer and but it is not something
where it's kind of the low level you're
taking all the steps according to the
way you want the computer or the way
that the computer is fundamentally set
up and as I was explaining kind of the
things that came from Babbage and
Lovelace and and uh you know the very
early computers at a nasoff and and the
eniac and all this kind of thing
um you know much of the thinking about
what a programming language should be
comes from the thinking about those very
early computers there are these
operations the computer does them we're
going to write down the the recipe for
what the computer should do
my Approach in thinking about
computational language has been sort of
a different approach it's kind of been
how do we think about things maybe in
mathematics maybe thinking about the
world in general and how do we write
that in a formal way much like logic as
a formalization of arguments there's a
sort of a formalization of things you
want to have happen in the world so to
speak how do you make a language like
that and then it's the job of of our
team to kind of build all of the what
you need to achieve the things that you
can describe in that computational
language well in any case until 2023 it
looked like a pretty good bet to just
you know you learn your Java programming
you can be a professional Java
programmer for decades and all is good
um of course now people realize that
llms can write low-level languages they
can write well from language code as
well they do a lot better at writing
wolf and language code than they can at
these lower level languages for very
practical reasons right now to do with
contact sizes and so on but also because
you know in Wilson language everything
they learned from all of that general
knowledge on the web and so on that
involves words and such like that is
sort of encapsulated and and condensed
in more from language where we're using
words to represent these sort of
computational operations and it's
something where it's realistic for an
llm to to learn that well and so on but
but you know the the fact is when you're
building a substantial Tower of
functionality you can't expect that the
things you've just described in pure
language to an llam will be correctly
represented and that's why you know it's
become very clear that orphan language
is this great kind of way of you look at
what you describe something to the llm
it produces a piece of language code you
can read it because it's a language
intended for humans to read as well as
computers you see what you've got you
decide okay that part is good that's a
solid kind of foundation brick now we
can build all the series of of you know
build a big tower on top of that and
that's that seems to be a really good
workflow that we're just learning now
but so then the question is okay we've
got all these sort of programmers and uh
who are learning these little other
languages and what's going to happen to
them well the answer is they're going to
get automated away and in a sense that
is absolutely no surprise to somebody
like me because that's the path you know
we've been on for 40 years of building
these layers of automation now you know
what does that mean for universities
that have tooled up to program to you
know to program the programmers so to
speak to provide all of that kind of
trade school education in a sense much
of that education is a bizarre kind of
uh you know it's sort of a plug-in to
the university in many ways because the
kind of the the the kind of the flow of
of of learning in and kind of just learn
to program it's a bit different from the
flow of learning in some of these more
less trade and skill oriented and more
academic and intellectually oriented
Fields now you know like the scribal
schools of ancient Babylon the you know
the scribes learned how to write and
then they had to figure out what were
they going to write about
in computer science departments there
has been a certain amount of sort of
attaching these areas like I don't know
cryptography machine learning
um
uh
uh what are some others um oh my gosh
I'm blanking
um on you know maybe a little bit of
data science although that's had a
complicated history at universities data
science has sort of in some cases grown
out of business schools statistics
departments which have kind of budded
off from math departments sometimes from
from kind of a social science area where
people were doing uh sort of
um uh kind of statistical analysis and
social sciences and things
um different different kinds of places
and and quite often the data science is
as sort of emerged in Business Schools
but
that's again a sort of a separate
tradition from the the learn to program
computer science tradition which is yet
a separate tradition from the
theoretical computer science tradition
and um uh but but you know there's been
this question of what really is computer
science now you know the thing that is
very clear is that there's a kind of
computational X for all X there's a
computational way to think about all
these different fields I mean the way I
see it these days sort of a
computational thinking about a field is
about formalizing that field
it's the same as what logic did for
argument so to speak it's a
formalization of whatever it is
archeology zoology whatever it is it's a
formalization which happens to have the
great feature that can be assisted by
computers once you've formalize things
then your computer is off and running
and can help you and so I see this as
being kind of this whole idea of
formalizing Fields formalizing one's way
of thinking about things this is a
tremendously General thing and it has
little to do with kind of low-level
programming and so you know the thing
that I think is is perhaps you know
computer science
somewhat
I don't know it's uh has become
identified with this learn to program
tradition
computer science as an academic
intellectual area is something rather
different from that but the learn to
program thing is a and learn you know
methodologist of managing large
programming software uh things and so on
that's um
that's in the kind of learn to program
strand which is now what people call
Computer Science I kind of think there's
a computational x c x not CS that is
kind of this whole learn to think
formally learn to think computationally
and you know it's necessary to know how
to formulate things in a kind of formal
computational way even if your goal is
even if you're basically in a telen LM
to write all the steps of the program or
you might write a little piece of
language code then you plug it into
something that Olam has produced for you
and keep going it's really a
tremendously powerful possibility it's
something that will be the future of
kind of the way people think about kind
of uh you know that this is formalizing
things is the way you build big towers
of ideas without that it's kind of like
always at the always this kind of a
surface level thing to to formalize is
to make sort of a solid block that you
can build in a big tower and that's what
you know mathematics has been done in a
particularly successful way
um it's something that we are you know
getting to do in this
computationalization of all these
different fields
so you know I it's a very interesting
question what will happen as sort of
computation changes its character away
from kind of the need for large numbers
of low-level programmers because that is
something that God automated away but
it's getting is going to get automated
away just as you know Assembly Language
programming long ago got largely
automated Away by compilers from C and
other languages and so
the the good news about sort of what can
be done with all Amazon computation is
many more people can make use of
computation it's a it's a great
broadening of the access to computation
and that will be true at universities as
well as other places there are many you
know departments and people and
professors and so on who will now
routinely be able to do things
computationally and formalize what
they're thinking about in computational
terms and get a computer to help them
than were possible before that's the
good news the bad news is the demand for
straight sort of trade like programmers
is going to go down and this big sort of
bubble I think it will be seen as of you
know everybody wants to go to school to
learn to be a programmer that's probably
over or will be over and I think that
the um uh so sort of it's a challenge at
this point because more people want to
know about kind of the ideas of
computation but the kind of mechanical
teaching of you know learn to write you
know Loops in Python something it's just
going to go away I mean it's just uh
that's that sort of not
not going to be a thing going forward
except for a small group of people just
like there's a small group of people
that absolutely no one a similar
language and and program in it and so on
but and that's necessary for kind of the
big stack of technology that we have in
the world
but I think uh so you know it's a very
interesting question what will happen
for example at universities as these
shifts occur
now there's also the K-12 world and the
K-12 world has a terrible history in
terms of programming because there have
been many rounds of efforts to really
teach coding programming whatever you
call it in the K-12 sector each one has
has kind of um sort of largely failed
um I think the first serious one was was
in the 1960s with basic and John Cameron
at Dartmouth
um mathematician who uh had this time
sharing system and developed this
language called basic which is quite
good
um and that was a sort of an early way
people learned some programming then
there was kind of a more uh sort of a a
bring it to even earlier ages this was
well that that was programming sort of
at the college level
um that had extended a bit to some high
school students in New York City and
other places
um the um then
I think also in the 1960s Seymour papert
worked on sort of using computers for
younger kids invented logo and you know
the turtle moving around the screen and
so on that was kind of based on a turtle
that a person called gray Walter had
made in the 1950s as an example of
Robotics and feedback control actually
and things like this
but um that was another initiative which
got some some momentum and and continues
to have in the form of scratch and other
things that have come from from logo
um but it's not really quite the same
you know I think the transferability of
the skills that you learn from scratch
to sort of serious computational
thinking seems to me a bit unconvincing
was more convincing in days when when
the average kid had never seen a
computer and the idea that you could get
a computer to do something you told it
to do was very novel but that idea is
obviously not novel to any kid who's
been born in the last 20 years or more
and so I think the um
the thing that um uh then then there
were these different waves of you know
let's teach oh gosh I can't even
remember them uh there was a oh there
was a pascal wave there was a um
uh I think there was a was there a C
programming wave I'm not sure there's a
Java wave there was a JavaScript wave
there's a python wave there's a um uh
oh what are the ones there's uh you know
The Little Wave mini waves of um of I
know Swift I think has a has some a push
in that direction lots of different
things it tends to be the case that very
few of these
you know first of all it's hard to write
an interesting program in raw Java let's
say
and the programs tend to be very
desiccated and kind of one of the
takeaways for kids ends up being oh gosh
this coding thing is really dull just
like kind of mechanical math is really
dull now there'll be some subset of kids
who say this is great and they're going
to become software Engineers whatever
else working and writing Java code for
example but for the vast majority it's
like why am I doing this it's incredibly
mechanical it's really boring
and the I think the thing that we've
seen with uh what's been done with you
know with World Language and so on is
that it's a place where kids can use the
exact same technology as the fanciest
you know research scientists and so on
use but kids can also immediately
because it's a computational language
that talks about real things in the
world kids can immediately kind of uh
um
look at things with a computer that are
things they care about whether it's
geography or whether it's music or
whether it's whatever else these are
things that the language knows about
it's not just dealing with arrays of
numbers and things like that it's not
you know it it knows the words in
English it's not oh you have to find a
dictionary to import from somewhere Etc
et cetera Etc it's um and so that makes
it at least in my observation just
vastly more compelling as a as a medium
for teaching and I think you know a lot
has been done on that vastly more could
be done I think that um the thing that
um
is uh I've been interested in well okay
so so that's kind of a a different play
so to speak on what you can teach but
what's tended to happen in using
low-level programming languages for
teaching is that to make them
interesting you have to kind of embed
them in things like a game environment
at which point you are barely talking
about the actual programming language
you're really talking about you know the
particular setup of this game and it
becomes something much more like scratch
where you've got just these particular
things of moving the cat around or
whatever else it is which are I don't
know how related they are to sort of
true computational thinking to me
computational thinking is all about how
do you take the things you are otherwise
thinking about in the world and
represent them in some formal way and I
think that's really different from what
you get given that you are constrained
by the particular operations that you've
been provided by your sort of low-level
programming language that's a different
way of thinking about things stand let
me take the things I'm really thinking
about in The World At Large and and put
them into into sort of a formal uh
structure now you know when you look at
what people actually do in in things
like scratch and so on you often find
well they're they're doing things that
are like representations of pictures and
they're sort of uh you know animating
some picture or something like this in a
sense a large part of that story is kind
of the picture and a much smaller part
of the story is the formalization of the
process and so on that goes into it
um
let's see well I think okay so so the
question about
um
what
will happen with them
with kind of the new age of AI and so on
and certainly what seems to be the case
I mean it's it's really quite remarkable
how well llms can do things like explain
what went wrong in a piece of open
language code
and the you know I fully expect that the
sort of personalized education writing
you know computational language will
become a thing and you know that will
again broaden the set of people who can
be exposed to this kind of computational
way of thinking about things I think one
of the things that's sort of a challenge
which uh I probably will end up having
to having to work on is okay you're
going to tell people about how do you
think about the world computationally
what does that actually mean it doesn't
mean teaching for Loops it doesn't mean
talking about variables it it doesn't it
means sort of you know what are the
things that I don't know somebody like
me who spent their life basically
working on sort of computationally
thinking about the world what are the
kinds of things that one knows that are
worth kind of explaining to other people
because it allows them to be able to
like sort of a computational way to
think about the world a way to formalize
what they see in the world and to kind
of build from there and I think that's a
an important definition now now how that
plugs into the existing world of
University education K-12 education
that's a that's a horribly complicated
challenge you know I think the specific
question that was asked here
um
the uh
um about
um when the degrees in programming
become significant you know I think
that's one of these things where
there was a period of time
for many kinds of degrees
there have been these periods where
that's the that's the hot thing to have
as a this or that degree there's always
a tale it always lasts you know but a
degree in programming which which isn't
you know it's not like a um uh that's
actually funny that that hasn't
developed you know it's like you can be
a master of Public Health or something
or you can be a you know and that's an a
different degree designation name than
you know a generic master's degree or
some some such other thing
um I I do find it amusing actually now
that I think about it that there is no
to my knowledge professional
certification of I'm a you know a BCS or
something
um that uh is sort of I'm now and
perhaps that's a consequence of the fact
that thankfully the idea of sort of
certifying programmers
um which was floated in the 1970s and
early 1980s didn't come to pass because
I think it's a deeply undefined thing I
mean it reminds me of register your AI
what's an AI I mean you know it's it's
like saying oh you've got to you know
some government you know some place
where it's like the government insists
you register every AI just like you
register every cat a cat is a much
better defined object than an AI and you
know exactly what that means is is quite
unclear
um
all right I should probably wrap up in a
moment you guys are asking just all
sorts of interesting questions here
um
there's a question from Des about
Wittgenstein and language and have any
relevance to llms and AI
um I know probably a lot less about
Wittgenstein than I know about AI
um so uh but I think
this kind of um
um
the idea of the extent to which language
is defined by thought and thought is
defined by language so to speak
um is an interesting one and in a sense
the llms very much do the kind of
linguistic philosophy kind of um
um you know thought is defined by
language type of thing because they
really are a language model they're a
model in which all they know is how to
complete sentences in the way that they
are typically completed now the thing we
realize upon looking at this is that's
kind of what Aristotle knew about and
what caused him to invent logic and
there are no doubt I've written about
this this kind of idea of semantic
grammar where there are these kind of
forms of meaning that are abstractable
from natural language but you know as it
is the AIS just know about how to
complete pieces of natural language and
that's that's their whole story and they
very much give evidence for the fact
that you can get a long way by just
thinking in terms of language so to
speak and what you can't get to are
certain kinds of things that involve
deeper computation that involve these
kind of whole stacks of computation
that's not something where just knowing
you know this is the way to complete the
sentence that's not really enough for
that and in fact in the case of an llam
like chat gbt the um sort of the outer
loop that says now you put down the next
token now you put down the next word
whatever it is that outer loop which
seems almost trivial because the main
Machinery is the neural net the 175
billion weights that are all computed
with every time you figure out the
probabilities for new words but turns
out that outer loop is pretty important
and it is I think the development of
that outer loop the further development
of that Outer Loop in a sense the you
know a serious deep computation is all
Outer Loop and much less in a you know
flow through a neural net the operations
inside are much in a sense simpler
better defined but there's a lot more
you know there's an a much bigger kind
of um uh sort of sequentialization or or
you know a longer chain of those
operations that are done whereas in an
llm it's kind of like the big effort is
making putting out each token and but
there's this sort of outer loop that's
defining which token should we put out
and and when an llm you know calls a
tool like the wolfen plugin for chat GPT
what's happening is that the llm is
actually just generating a piece of
language like stuff that you as a user
don't happen to see because the front
end of the whole thing but for the for
the language model it's just like it put
down something saying call the wolf and
plugin and then goes off it does a
computation then our plugin writes back
a piece of essentially text which
becomes the next thing that the the
language model sees it reads that and
then it it doesn't show you any of that
stuff unless you open those little boxes
um in the in the user interface and then
it keeps going and uh and makes use of
the results it got
but this idea you know I think we're
beginning to see a much sharper form
this kind of idea of what language is
versus what thinking is versus what
computation is and I think that really
is all clarifying and I should learn
more about what but can Stone actually
wrote about those kinds of things
and I should wrap up here for now thank
you for all these interesting questions
and comments and uh I gotta go to my day
job and do
um
another live stream here so thanks for
joining me and bye for now